des admirateurs de margaret atwood
faisait la file en pleine nuit à londres
pour mettre la main sur la suite de son
roman succès la servante écarlate à
montréal aussi des lecteurs étaient
impatients d'en faire la lecture j'ai
besoin d'aller bien achète tout de suite
sp c'est ça que je fais que j'étais très
excité pour l acheter aujourd'hui j'ai
couru dans l'oeuf
mais j'ai la santé c'est ma fête
aujourd'hui agent alors j'attendais pour
lâcher pour ma fête
véritable phénomène le roman la servante
écarlate paru en 1985 s'est vendu à 8
millions d'exemplaires ce récit met en
scène une société totalitaire et
religieuse où la femme est réduite à
l'esclavagisme sexuel et à
l'asservissement
oui ça a eu quand même un assez grand
impact surtout quand j'ai compris en
fait que dans sa démarche et s'était
inspirée uniquement de faits historiques
que j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui était qui était vraiment
intéressant en crise et puis à réfléchir
le roman a fait l'objet d'une série
télévisée acclamé de toutes parts dre de
35 ans après le premier livre
margaret atwood publie la suite qui
porte le nom les testaments là ce
livre-là elle y pense à l'immense
pendant toutes ces années là une
trentaine d'années elle est rendue à
avoir 80 et 81 e en avant quand même
donc il ya beaucoup de maturité beaucoup
de vécu beaucoup de lucidité alors elle
s'est inspirée de la crise financière
est inspiré de l'ascension au pouvoir de
donner dans le monde mais ottawa
margaret atwood est sans l'ombre d'un
doute une des plus grande écrivaine
canadienne
même si elle a tenu des propos
controversés sur le mouvement moi aussi
ces livres sont un symbole important
chez les féministes je pense que oui je
pense qu'il y en a beaucoup d'autres
il ya des féministes sont allés aussi
plus loin qui ont poursuivi qui ont
construit sur sept et blocs qui sont
allés plus loin dans des dans des
réflexions qui dans ces sujets là mais
je pense qu'un effectivement c'est
surtout dans le contexte d'aujourd'hui
c'est une autre estime qu ont compris
qu'on doit lire à peine sorti en
librairie le livre les testaments et
déjà en lice pour le man booker prize du
royaume uni et au canada
il est en nomination pour le prix
guehrer déjà une adaptation télévisée
est en chantier
un événement en direct avec margaret
atwood est présenté ce soir dans plus de
1000 cinéma à travers le monde dont sept
dans la région de montréal
la traduction française du nouveau livre
de margaret atwood débarquera en
librairie le 11 octobre prochain
et l'engouement est tel que pour le
québec seulement son éditeur a procédé à
un premier tirage de 30000 exemplaires
ici nous et c'est le puits mais
radio-canada mots rien